flickenteppich beim imf tempo die
bundesländer kommen mit den crooner
injektionen sehr unterschiedlich voran
schulstart im shutdown zum ferienende
stecken die kultusminister ab wie es für
die klassen weitergehen soll und skandal
anrufe in georgia us-präsident schon
fordert vom innenminister stimmen für
ihn zu finden und das wahlergebnis zu
kippen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
meiner seite ist norbert lehmann für den
sport ein moderator von mir hat
deutschland zu wenig impfstoff bestellt
und warum geht das mit den impfungen
nicht schneller
selbst regierungssprecher steffen
seibert räumte ein das ist derzeit noch
nicht an allen stellen optimal laufe
bevor wir die politische diskussion
abbilden erst mal ein blick auf die
fakten
bislang wurden fast 266.000 erste dosen
verabreicht dabei gibt es allerdings
große unterschiede zwischen den
bundesländern ganz vorn mecklenburg
vorpommern mit 7,1 impfungen pro 1000
einwohner bayern kommt auf 5
schlusslicht ist thüringen mit gerade
mal 0,4 jürgen kehl hat details heute
mittag war die ärztin da sie haben sie
jetzt hinter sich
79 senioren im betreuten wohnen weimar
immer wieder hatte die verwaltung auf
den impftermin gedrängt endlich hat es
nun geklappt
wir gehen auf dem zahnfleisch es sind
die neue einrichtung alleine gelassen
für uns hatte den ganzen sommer über
einen plan entwurf werden kann
das ist nicht passiert ist und alleine
und es ist für uns wirklich eine schwere
zeit die lage ist kompliziert viele
heime gerade in thüringen sind in
quarantäne
im teams haben dann kaum zugang und
außerdem braucht man von jedem bewohner
eine einverständniserklärung
dazu braucht es auch die zeit eine gute
aufklärung und das ist uns besonders
wichtig wir wollen hohe
durchimpfungsquote in den
pflegeeinrichtungen und nicht nur ein
paar wenige die sich vielleicht auf die
schnelle bereit erklärt haben längst
nicht alle in den heimen wollen geimpft
werden beispiel planegg bei münchen 14
corona tote sind hier zu beklagen zwei
drittel der bewohner ließen sich jetzt
impfen aber nur ein viertel des
pflegepersonals die nebenwirkung sind
vielleicht auch noch nicht so ganz klar
und da sind viele junge leute sind da
zufällig schleswig holstein geht jetzt
den weg der den durchbruch bringen soll
ein teil der impfzentren macht heute auf
anlaufstelle für alle impfwilligen über
80 und das gesamte pflegepersonal
damit ist dann norden weiter als viele
andere bundesländer
so öffnet etwa rheinland pfalz auch
diese woche sachsen nächsten montag
hessen übernächste woche und das
bevölkerungsreiche nordrhein westfalen
erst im februar
vorher sei einfach nicht genug impfstoff
da biotec pfizer liefert wie verabredet
670.000 dosen pro woche
aber reicht das selbst innerhalb der
regierung gibt es kritik
spd-generalsekretär kling bei moniert
deutschland stehe bei der impfstoff
menge im vergleich zu anderen ländern
schlecht da er spricht von chaotischen
zuständen christiane hübscher hat mir
hoffnung sollte die impfung bringen und
so wirbt die bundesregierung um
akzeptanz
jetzt haben wir auch einen wirksamen
impfstoff
doch kommt er zu langsam gibt es zu
wenig als in berlin das corona kabinett
zusammen kommt hat der cdu
gesundheitsminister gerade öffentlich
der bestellte vom koalitionspartner
eingesteckt aus den ländern erlebe ich
dass sie alles vorbereitet haben dass
die impfzentren stehen aber das einfach
keine impfstoffe da sind und ich finde
dass das kann nicht sein dass ein land
in dem dieser impfstoff sogar erforscht
wurde dass wir am ende zu wenig dosen
machen hätte die bundesregierung bei den
beiden biontech gründern aus mainz
frühzeitig und zusätzlich zu den eu
verträgen mehr impfstoff bestellen
müssen
spannend sprecher lehnt eine
verantwortung für den schleppenden
impfstart ab
das problem ist nicht die bestellmenge
das problem ist die produktionskapazität
ab dem sommer hatte sich die eu
kommission bei sechs herstellern
impfstoff gesichert niemand wusste
damals wer als erster ins ziel kommen
würde
der vertrag mit beyond advisor wurde
erst im november geschlossen eine
dreiviertelstunde lang muss der
regierungssprecher heute kritische
fragen beantworten
natürlich ist nicht alles perfekt und
man muss sich jeden tag auch dann fragen
was kann man noch tun damit es besser
wird minister sparen lässt prüfen ob man
den abstand zwischen erster und zweiter
impfung vergrößern könnte von derzeit 21
tagen auf maximal 42 wie von der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde jetzt
erlaubt so könnten mehr menschen zügig
einen ersten schutz erhalten
chacon talabani in berlin wie berechtigt
ist die kritik an der bundesregierung
naja wie bei jedem großprojekt sind
kritische nachfragen immer berechtigt
und insbesondere in diesem fall war ja
die impfung für bund und länder
eigentlich immer die einzige
langfriststrategie gewesen ist jetzt
über den gesamten verlauf der korona
krise dann sollte das impfen auch
klappen
offene fragen müssten jetzt also
schleunigst beantwortet werden das ist
wichtig für das vertrauen in das gesamte
maßnahmenpaket von bundesregierung und
bundesländern
was allerdings nicht reicht ist jetzt
schon mit dem finger auf einzelne zu
zeigen dann müsste man sich bei diesem
großen projekt tatsächlich alle
stationen angucken die europäische
strategie dass bund länder konzept und
die frage wie es vor ort also zum
beispiel in den kommunen umgesetzt wird
jetzt schon ein abschließendes fazit zu
ziehen wäre sicherlich recht früh wird
bei dieser ganzen debatte auch schon der
wahlkampf seine schatten voraus
also richtiges wahlkampfgetöse ist das
noch nicht auch wenn wir den
spd-generalsekretär heute schon mit
deutlichen worten gehört haben aber das
bild bietet einen vorgeschmack auf das
was in diesem jahr noch kommen wird wenn
cdu/csu und spd gemeinsam regieren und
gleichzeitig gegeneinander wahlkampf
führen und sich da auch voneinander
absetzen müssen das wird bei den großen
entscheidungen die in diesem jahr
anstehen mit der bekämpfung der korona
krise aber auch der klimapolitik zum
beispiel sicher noch einige
auseinandersetzungen geben und bestimmt
nicht ganz ohne blessuren ab gehen die
einschätzungen von unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondenten dankeschön
schreck unterlag
wie steht es um die neuinfektionen in
deutschland hier die aktuellen zahlen
das robert koch institut meldet neun
1847 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
302 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus allerdings sind die daten nach
weihnachten dem jahreswechsel und dem
wochenende wohl noch unvollständig
unverändert heftig wütet corona in
sachsen in keinem anderen bundesland
liegen die neuinfektionen pro 100.000
einwohnern innerhalb von sieben tagen so
hoch nämlich bei 323 und die höchste
instanz hat seit tagen der vogtlandkreis
aktuell 632 über die hintergründe städte
moritz gift haben fremde auf das neue
impfzentrum in treuen im vogtlandkreis
gesprüht ausgerechnet in dem landkreis
der mit einer sieben tage incidents von
632 negativ spitzenreiter in deutschland
ist den einwohnern fallen
erklärungsversuch es schwer alle leben
haben zu
silvester war ein großes spiel los ich
denke weil die vielen partys machen um
ja sie halten nicht anregen
vor einigen tagen waren die werte sogar
noch erheblich höher
dass sie nun tendenziell wieder nach
unten zeigen macht dem landrat mut eine
norma rückstau bei der bearbeitung der
fälle sei der hauptgrund gewesen aber
nicht nur den hohen altersdurchschnitt
haben wir haben deshalb probleme 50%
unsere infektionen sind im pflegebereich
also bewohner der pflegeheime das
personal und im krankenhaus als auch
viele im krankenhaus die betten sind ja
sehr stark ausgelastet mehr als die
hälfte der intensivbetten im
vogtlandkreis sind mit einem koma
patienten belegt nur noch acht freie
betten stehen derzeit zur verfügung
die verlängerung des shutdown scheint
unausweichlich
davor graut axel seidel dessen firma mit
100 leuten im vogtland mode produziert
und vertreibt mode die derzeit niemand
abnimmt
das ist wirtschaftlich gesehen sehr sehr
hart weil ich kann jetzt keine neue ware
ausliefern weil der händler aktuell
nichts abnehmen kann der händler zeugt
aber auch keine offenen rechnungen
aktuell war kein einnahmen hat wichtiger
war ihm aber dass heute morgen alle
mitarbeiterinnen zur arbeit erschienen
sind keine krank alle halten sich wohl
an die regeln
das würde er sich für alle vogtländer
wünschen
in einigen bundesländern ging heute die
schule wieder los corona bedingt zu
hause und die schüler werden wohl auch
weiterhin erstmal zu hause lernen müssen
trotz aller nachteile die kultusminister
wollen erst nach und nach die schulen
wieder öffnen wann genau soll jedes
bundesland selbst entscheiden je nach
infektions lage lisa ja nie berichtet
claudia clemens ist mutter und politik
lehrerin an einer berliner schule ihr
mann musiklehrer
die schule hat für sie heute wieder
angefangen vom heimischen arbeitszimmer
aus ihr wunsch ich wünsche mir dass die
abschlussklassen möglichst gleich
nachdem lockdown die möglichkeit haben
in halb gruppen in die schule zu kommen
die kultusminister haben sich auf ein
stufenmodell zur rückkehr in den
präsenzunterricht geeinigt erst sollen
die jüngsten wieder in die schule kommen
dann soll es wechsel unterricht geben in
stufe drei präsenzunterricht für alle
ausnahmen gelten je nach schule für die
abschlussklassen den ländern die
niedrige incidence werte haben da kann
man sich natürlich früher schon ein
wechsel in den hybride unterricht oder
natürlich auch den präsenzunterricht
vorstellen
in ländern mit höheren intelligenz sind
wie sachsen thüringen aber insbesondere
auch bayern da werden wir sicherlich
vorsichtiger seien unklar bleibt
allerdings wann genau welche stufe
eintritt elternvertreter fordern
wichtig ist vor allen dingen dass die
schulen nicht anfangen stress zu machen
jetzt haben wir wenig präsenz und man
muss noch versuchen alle möglichen
kassen arbeiten in einer woche zu
schreiben dass der leistungsdruck
entsteht
ich glaube das ist das was in den
nächsten wochen sensibel behandelt
werden muss als mutter und als lehrerin
wünscht sich claudia clemens vor allem
klarheit wie es bis zu den winterferien
weitergehen soll
woran hakt es bei den corona impfungen
fragen wie diese können sie den
niedersächsischen gesundheitsministerin
stellen um 19 uhr 30 bei zdf heute live
über youtube facebook oder unsere app
einen überblick über neue entwicklungen
gibt es jederzeit in corona block in der
zdf- heute- app an julian assange
scheiden sich die geister
für die einen ist der gründer der
internetplattform wikileaks ein
engagierter journalist der
kriegsverbrechen aufgedeckt hat für die
amerikanische regierung ist er ein
verräter von staatsgeheimnissen heute
entschied ein britisches gericht der 49
jährige darf nicht an die usa
ausgeliefert werden
wegen seines labilen psychischen
zustands yaz in irland
es ist eine entscheidung auf die julian
assange unterstützer gehofft hatten
die richterin in london befand
angesichts der haftbedingungen die ihn
in den usa erwarteten bestehe die gefahr
dass assange sich das leben nehmen
der heutige sieg ist der erste schritt
in richtung gerechtigkeit in diesem fall
der argumentation der verteidigung
assange diese habe als journalist
geholfen kriegsverbrechen aufzudecken
folgte das gericht allerdings nicht sein
vorgehen sei über das normale verhalten
investigative journalisten hinaus
gegangen so die richterin
zehn jahre ist es inzwischen her dass
assange wikileaks filmmaterial und
dokumente veröffentlichte die vor allem
für die usa unliebsame details an den
tag brachten wie diese aufnahmen von
amerikanischen soldaten die auf
zivilisten im irak feiern
aber auch papiere die dazu führen
konnten agenten zu enttarnen und zu
gefährden wie behauptet wurde
kurz darauf verließ schweden einen
internationalen haftbefehl gegen assange
wegen vergewaltigung und sexueller
nötigung
ein verfahren das mittlerweile jedoch
eingestellt ist was angst über schweden
an die usa ausgeliefert zu werden pro
jahr 2012 in die ecuadorianische
botschaft in london sieben jahre haus
der dort auf engstem raum
doch sein politisches asyl bei den
südamerikanern endete im april 2009 10
seither ist assange wegen verstoßes
gegen seine kautionsauflagen in haft
über eine neuerliche kaution soll am
mittwoch beschieden werden die usa haben
gegen das urteil berufung eingelegt
der us bundesstaat georgia ist seit der
präsidentschaftswahl im november ein
zünglein an der waage zum ersten mal
seit fast drei jahrzehnten viel georgia
an die demokraten
doch das will der noch amtierende
präsident partout nicht akzeptieren
gebetsmühlenartig spricht donald trump
von wahlbetrug und legte jetzt noch
einen drauf in einem telefongespräch
forderte er den verantwortlichen
wahlleiter auf stimmen für ihn zu finden
peter jäger der us-präsident
wutentbrannt am telefon
ich will einfach nur elf 1780 stimmen
finden
[Musik]
am anderen ende der leitung der
innenminister von george a er soll
stammt die stimmen besorgen die ihm
angeblich gestohlen worden
sie sollten eine korrekte wahl wollen
sie sind republikaner
wir glauben wir hatten eine korrekte
wahl innenminister ravensburger ist auch
oberster wahlaufseher in georgia hatte
nach mehreren nachzählungen das ergebnis
und den sieg beides bestätigt auf trams
wahlbetrugs theorien will er sich nicht
einlassen der präsident droht sie wissen
was gelaufen ist aber melden es nicht
das ist eine straftat das ist ein großes
risiko
das ist ein tonband beweis derzeit wozu
der präsident bereit ist um das
wahlsystem zu untergraben und illegal
und unmoralisch einen ko anzuzetteln
macht missbraucht meint auch die
künftige vize präsidentin herres gerade
auf wahlkampftour in georgia aus dem
abgewählten präsidenten spreche die
stimme der verzweiflung am abend
sprechen in dem bundesstaat auch der
künftige präsident biden und tom selbst
vor anhängern
dort steht morgen die stichwahl um zwei
senatssitze an deren ausgang wird
entscheiden welche partei im
washingtoner senat das sagen hat der
land es dass es der name eines neuen
autogiganten eine fusion der die
aktionäre des peugeot konzerns und von
fiat chrysler jetzt zugestimmt
still und es wird nach absatz der
viertgrößte autohersteller sein er führt
14 marken wie peugeot citroën gibt und
auch opel
was dieser zusammenschluss für die
opelaner bedeutet zeigt dieser welt de
la vega schicht ende bei opel in
rüsselsheim
die nachricht von der fusion der
konzernmutter mit fiat chrysler
polarisiert ich hab gerade ist er angst
vor dem arbeitsplatzabbau großen
schlimmer an
auf der anderen seite
entwicklungszentrum das
entwicklungszentrum von opel mit seinen
rund 4500 mitarbeitern könnte nun
besonders unter druck geraten
denn psa und fiat chrysler bringen
zusammen rund 18.000 ingenieure in den
neuen autoriesen 1
zu viele meinen experten gerade in der
größe des konzerns aber läge auch seine
chance das unternehmen was dann doppelt
so groß wird quasi hat einfach
wesentlich mehr einkaufsmacht zum
beispiel und da spielt in der zukunft
ebenso eine rolle wie entwicklungskosten
psa-chef tavares bleibt die nummer eins
im konzern
der manager brachte opel in die
gewinnzone zurück über 6.000 stellen
wurden dabei abgebaut dieser kurs könnte
sich nun noch einmal verschärfen
tavares ist bekannt als knallharter
sanierer der immer mit wenig
mitarbeitern viel profit arbeiten
erarbeiten wird der wert mit ganz harten
konditionen in suhl iva geschäft gehen
also zulieferer in europa und die
beschäftigten bei opel die ziehen den
schwarzen peter zum hoffnungsträger für
opel werden nun mehr denn je die
elektromodelle denn da gibt es im
gesamten neuen konzern viel
nachholbedarf
eines ist nur durch die korona pandemie
gelungen deutschland hat sein
klimaschutzziel für 2020 offenbar nicht
nur erreicht sondern sogar übertroffen
eine folge der krise und des milden
winters allerdings warnen experten
eine pandemie könne keine klimapolitik
ersetzen
marco hat details
noch vor einem jahr stand nicht nur für
klima- aktivisten fest deutschland wird
2020 das klimaziel krachend verfehlen
und jetzt das nach einer ersten analyse
wird es sogar noch übertroffen gut 42
prozent weniger treibhausgase im
vergleich zu 1990 also zwei prozent
besser als geplant
die gründe hohe co2 preise in europa
machten kohle teuer dass weniger
schmutzige gas war dagegen günstig und
im milden winter wurde weniger geheizt
der hauptgrund aber war corona in der
krise brach die kohle energie ein der
verkehr ging stark zurück
nur ein drittel dieser emissionsmenge
ist wirklicher klimaschutz der rest ist
wirtschaftskrise und das ist natürlich
nichts worüber man froh sein kann was
wir brauchen ist emissionsfrei option
durch investitionen weil die bringen
nachhaltig dauerhaft emissionsreduktion
und stärken gleichzeitig die wirtschaft
denn eine echte trendwende sieht die
analyse noch nicht erwartet wird ein
deutlicher anstieg vor allem in
industrie und verkehr nach der krise bei
aller kritik in berlin sieht man das
erreichen des ziels auch als eigene
leistung obwohl es ohne corona nicht
ganz geklappt hätte
das ist davon gesprochen worden dass das
klimaziel krachend verfehlt wird jetzt
sind wir auf auch ohne corona fast dran
gekommen und das ist natürlich
ermutigend klimapolitik kann etwas
bewegen muss auch etwas bewegen
für 2030 liegt das klimaziel übrigens
bei 55 prozent und damit noch mal
deutlich früher das auch dabei wieder
eine krise nach hilft hofft wohl niemand
ernsthaft
und jetzt gibt es den ersten
weltmeistertitel des jahres ja und dann
hat gewinn preiserhöhungen bei der darts
wm in london
der walliser besiegte gestern abend den
schotten gary anderson der preis für
preis 1 25 kilogramm schwere pokal und
500.000 pfund
ein besonderer sieger in einer
besonderen atmosphäre ex rugby spieler
gewinn preis krönt ein erfolgreiches
jahr mit dem weltmeistertitel im
legendären alexandra palace
schon im ersten satz offenbart gegner
gary anderson schwächen die kevin price
ausnutzen kann
er überzeugt mit gewaltigen doppel
trefferquoten und liegt nach dem 8 satz
mit 6 zu 2 in führung
am ende braucht es zehn sätze und zwölf
matches bis zum sieg der den walliser an
die spitze der darts welt bringt ich
konnte es erst mal nicht glauben dass
ich wirklich gewonnen habe das ist ein
sehr seltsames gefühl und lässt sich
nicht in worte fassen
preis ist jetzt nicht nur neuer
weltmeister sondern durch den sieg auf
platz eins der weltrangliste
bo svensson wird neuer trainer beim
fußball- bundesligisten mainz 05 der
däne früher spieler und co trainer in
mainz folgt auf jan moritz lichte der
beim tabellenvorletzten vergangene woche
freigestellt worden war
ja ab morgen die entscheidung der
vierschanzentournee letzte station
bischofshofen
noch haben die dsv adler chancen auf
einen gesamt podestplatz karl geiger ist
vierter markus eisenbichler fünfter der
gesamtwertung
die trophäe für den gesamtsieg bei der
tournee müssen die deutschen wohl auch
in diesem jahr wieder anderen überlassen
denn die innsbrucker schanze auf dem
bergisel wurde erneut zum spielverderber
karl geiger nur 16 markus eisenbichler
immerhin sechster in bischofshofen ist
das ziel nun wenigstens das podest der
gesamtwertung ist sie mit dem klaren
ziel hierher gefahren um die tournee
sieg zu kämpfen und es hat mir
hundertprozentig funktioniert jeder hat
sein bestes gegeben und der den flug
verfolgt muss jetzt weiter und weiter
auf der erfolgsspur ist der pole kamil
stoch der morgen die grundlage für
seinen dritten gesamtsieg schaffen kann
die qualifikation dafür live im zdf von
16 uhr an ihren und opa brass jetzt noch
ein lied bei dem jeder fußballfan mit
gänsehaut bekommt ja absolut der anlass
ist traurig und doch geht das um das
schönste liebt der welt
[Applaus]
so nennt jedenfalls liverpool trainer
jürgen klopp you'll never walk alone die
fußball hymne schlechthin das wirklich
fast alle sie kennen und lieben
verdanken wir gary moore ssten der jetzt
mit 78 jahren gestorben ist er und seine
band die pacemakers haben das musical
die 1963 zum hit gemacht und inzwischen
gehört es allen fußballfans
[Applaus]
musik hilft auch bei depri wetter es
bleibt nämlich sehr trüb die details hat
gleich katja oliver marietta slomka
spricht im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn mit gesundheitsminister sparen
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen entspannten
abend bis morgen wenn sie mir
[Musik]
die namen meine damen und herren die
wolken über der ostsee ziehen weiter in
richtung westen in richtung
großbritannien und die wolken hier
nördlich der pyrenäen
die ziehen weiter richtung osten über
das mittelmeer und dann gibt es noch
wolken über südosteuropa und die ziehen
hier über ungarn weiter nordwärts alle
wolken ziehen also irgendwie um
deutschland herum und das bedeutet bei
uns morgen eher langweiliges wetter
heute nacht allerdings fällt noch schnee
schneeregen und es kann hier im
nordosten gefährlich glatt werden auf
den straßen im süden fällt weder schnee
noch regen da bildet sich auch mal nebel
die temperaturen sinken meist auf plus 2
bis minus zwei grad und nur über schnee
am alpenrand geht es bis -6 grad runter
und dort bleibt es auch morgen über tag
am kühlsten dauerfrost ich bei minus 1
grad sonst liegen die höchstwerte bei 0
bis 4 grad
das wird ein langweilig bedeckter tag ab
und zu fällt ein bisschen schnee
schneegriesel oder schneeregen aber viel
wird das in keinem fall und allenfalls
an den alpen haben sie eine gewisse
geringe chance auf sonnenschein am
mittwoch kommt dann im nordosten
kräftiger schneefall auf und am
donnerstag erreicht der dann auch den
westen dabei bleibt es kalt bei minus 1
bis plus 3 grad schönen abend noch